I've just been breaking news to bring
you from a lot of politics in Blackfoot
who is the leader of the SNP in
Westminster he has said that he is going
to be standing down as leader of the
Westminster parliamentary group uh he's
going to announce that at the S P's AGM
next week but he's not stepping down as
an MP uh he is the person who stands up
after uh kirst armor and prime
minister's questions uh acting as
another member a leading member of the
opposition to question the prime
minister so he's going to lose that role
he says he's been doing it for more than
five years but that now is the right
time for fresh leadership in Westminster
as we head towards a general election
and in his words the next steps in
winning Scotland's Independence uh he
says whilst I'm stepping down as
Western's leader I will continue with my
role as the MP for Ross sky in lock
Harbor and I've also accepted a new role
at the center of the snp's independence
campaign leading on business engagement
so he's going to be focusing very much
on his Nicholas surgeon's bid to fight
for independence for Scotland but we'll
be doing a little bit less in the House
of Commons but in Blackford remaining as
an MP